We would now like to look at
two-dimensional collisions.
And what we'd like to look at
is in the laboratory frame--
so I'll call that the lab
frame-- in which we have
a target particle, which
I'm going to call 2,
and an incoming particle
1, which is coming in
with some initial velocity.
After the collision,
let's imagine
that the target
particle is going out
at a certain direction.
So we'll call that 2.
And the target particle
has a velocity v2 final.
And the initial particle that's
going in this direction-- we'll
call that 1.
And that is it's
outcoming velocity.
Now in this collision, we
want to ask ourselves first,
what quantities are
constants of the motion.
Well, let's assume
no external forces,
therefore momentum is constant.
And we can write our
momentum equation
as m1 v1 initial equals m1
v1 final plus m2 v2 final.
Now recall that
momentum is a vector.
And so what we have here
are two-- the unknowns here
are our two outcoming vectors,
v1 final and v2 final.
And a vector in two
dimensions has two quantities.
We can discuss-- we can
write that as components.
Or we can write it in terms
of magnitudes and directions.
Now experimentally, we often
will measure the directions
of the outcoming
particles, which
I will now indicate by theta
2 final and theta 1 final.
And so, when we write our
two momentum equations,
we can either write
it as components,
or we can write it in terms
of magnitudes and directions
and do vector decomposition.
Now because we measure
the outcoming directions,
we're going to choose to do
magnitudes and directions.
So let's indicate
a little notation.
We'll say that the magnitude
of v1 initial is v1 i.
And the magnitude of
v2 final is v2 final.
v1 final is v1 final.
And so now, when we look at
our two momentum conditions,
we can-- we now also
have to introduce
unit vectors for directions.
So let's call i hat that way
and j hat in this direction.
And in our i hat
direction, we have
only the incoming momentum.
And we can write that
as m1 v1 initial.
It's positive because we've
chosen the forward direction
as our i hat direction.
Now in terms of the outgoing
momentum in the i hat
direction, we have to
do vector decomposition
of both of these vectors.
And they both have
positive components.
So we have m1 v1 final-- that's
the magnitude-- cosine theta
1 final plus-- positive
sign, because they're
both in the positive
direction-- v2 final magnitude
times-- we need that little-- m2
v2 final cosine theta 2 final.
And that is our i hat direction.
Now the j hat
direction-- remember,
we have to be careful, because
we're taking positive j hat up.
So our particle 2 has a positive
component in the j direction.
And our particle 1 has
a negative component
in the j direction.
The incoming momentum-- there's
no momentum in the j direction.
So we have a 0.
And that's equal to
positive m2 v2 final.
And that's a sine theta 2 final.
Now, here's where you
have to be careful,
because this one is negative.
Component is in the
negative j hat direction.
And we have m1 v1 final
sine theta 1 final.
And these two represent
our momentum equations.
Now we also have to think--
let's think about energy.
Again, we have to know
something about this collision.
And our assumption will be
that this particular collision
is elastic.
And that means the
initial kinetic energy
is equal to the
final kinetic energy.
Energy is a scalar.
We've been describing our
incoming velocity vectors
in terms of magnitudes.
So we can write our
elastic energy condition
as the incoming kinetic
energy squared--
that's the kinetic
energy incoming--
is equal to 1/2 m1 v1
final squared plus 1/2
m2 v2 final squared.
And that is our kinetic
energy condition.
Let's label this equation
1 and equation 2.
Now, it's very
important to realize
which quantities are given and
which we need to solve for.
So in this problem, because
the two outcoming velocities--
unknowns-- we have
four unknowns.
Those unknowns can be written
in terms of the two velocity
final and the other
one, v2 final.
Those are our vector quantities.
But recall, in terms of
the scalar magnitudes,
we have that v1 final.
And I'll just write the
other ones down-- v2 final,
and the two outgoing
directions-- theta 1 final
and theta 2 final.
So these are our four
unknown quantities.
But you can see we only
have three equations.
And therefore, if we want
to determine the outcomes,
we need to measure one
additional quantity.
Now that's very useful
when doing problem solving,
because when you start
to read a problem,
and you look at
what's being measured,
you can right away determine
which of the four quantities
has been given.
You may be given an outgoing
magnitude of the velocity,
or you may be given one of
these scattering angles.
And so that's how we approach
two-dimensional elastic
collision.
Of course there's
algebra now to solve
for any particular quantity
that you're interested
in, provided you have this
extra additional information.